Let's get my mom mobile ready for summer.
I tend to be a car hoarder.
This place is a disaster most of the time.
Look at the trunk of my car right now, guys.
This is what's left over after traveling
and basically living out of this thing.
So it was time to do a full refresh,
starting with tackling the mess.
I need my car to be functional and organized,
but still taking advantage of the fact that I have three rows
and not a big trunk.
I found this really great organizer on Amazon.
It hangs in the back of the third row and connects to the headrests
and just allows for so much more storage and organization.
I then grab some plastic bins to put in their activity stuff,
things that we're gonna need every week
because they have different activity.
And then I started filling the compartments with things that we need.
Bug spray, sunscreen,
diapers, and wipe.
Always gotta have a stack of balls in the back of the car,
and, of course,
beach towels. This is just the beginning.
I'm gonna add more stuff,
but it's definitely a transformation.